c'est la nouvelle mode du monde
merveilleux de la télé réalité se marier
avoir beaucoup d'enfants et vivre
heureux jusqu'ici c'est comme tout le
monde
rien d'anormal sauf que nos amis de la
télé réalité se met en scène avec leur
bébé sur les réseaux sociaux et même à
la télé pour faire toujours plus de buzz
les stars des marseillais manon marceau
et julien antilles ont été dans les
premiers à exposer leur fils tiago bonne
anniversaire et a priori le petit tiago
a les mêmes goûts que son papa niveau
voiture ce méga cab d'anniversaire la
famille tente ya même eu le droit à sa
propre série sur six plaies intitulé
manon plus julien égale bébé frat et
d'autres frappées marseillais sont allés
encore plus loin si si c'est possible
elle me l'étais comme il s'agit de kevin
et carla guedj qui ont carrément filmer
la naissance de leur fille ruby au et
offert six plaies ne pouvait pas passer
à côté d'un tel événement et ont donc
diffusé la série inédite car la plus
kevin égale bébé ruby la petite ruby
fait déjà du business sur les réseaux
elle compte déjà plus de 500 mille
abonnés sur instagram
pour terminer les derniers nés de la
grande famille de la télé-réalité son
maiden le fils de jessica et thibaut des
marseillais pour l'instant le couple ne
l'affichent pas trop et bien sûr millan
le tout jeune fils de nabila et thomas
qui a vu le jour il ya deux semaines
même si on a déjà vu la photo du petit
millan sur les réseaux de la villa
semble ne pas vouloir aller jusqu'à lui
créer un compte
comme elle l'a expliqué sur twitter je
n'exposerai jamais mon enfant de cette
manière je le présenterai jusqu'à mon
dernier souffle
alors après avoir vu toutes ces images
une question se pose alors selon vous
les influences se servent hôtel de leurs
enfants pour faire du blé
alors la question est posée pour parler
avec de l'eau on a rappelé que toi
djeddah les cno et bastien que j'ai mal
alors raffin il ya quelques jours j'ai
posté une vidéo
ouais c'était un coup de gueule on dire
voilà moi je ne supporte plus de voir
tous ses bébés de télé relève est mis en
avant
on revoit ses images on en parle juste
après les candidats de télé réalité qui
ont des enfants et ufo instagram
mais sur la tête de ma mère vous
respecter par votre enfant en fait un
enfant ça se protège quand vous êtes un
enfant c'est pour qui c'est pour les
jantes pour la communauté où c'est pour
vous je comprends pas c'est pour gagner
plus d'argent c'est pourquoi sur la
ville ma mère qu'on va protéger vos
enfants
arrêtez de faire des instagram ce n'est
pas possible dans quel monde on vit sur
la vie de ma mère
ils ont deux mois les diamants ou
instagram mais arrêtez arrêtez ça vous
êtes plutôt vous êtes plutôt pour une
fois ça vous dérange pas ouais moi ça me
dérange pas je suis plutôt pour et puis
surtout j'ai été très surpris de voir
cette vidéo que tu as fait tant donné
que toi tu es un des grands exemples des
gens qui ont vendu leur vie privée à la
télé parce que voulez vous d'autre part
donner des cours de respect des enfants
aux gens alors que toi tu es un mec qui
en manquent énormément la preuve qui
fait virer d'un dernier tournage pour
avoir alors je rappelle que j'ai encore
du matériel de chirurgie je ne peux pas
tout alors alors alors alors je vais
parce que je souris donc je faisais de
nom on parle d on parle du fait de
mettre des enfants après que lui me
l'avait privé sur le trône sur les
réseaux où on peut discuter sa
légitimité dans c'était pas aussi mais
il peut être choquer tiens toi tu en as
non ça je te pose est-ce que tu as les
enfants non je n'ai pas peur on a tu es
venu faire quoi ici et toi c'est quoi
une jeune homme était venu on vient ici
on n'est pas copains on se connaît pas
tu sais très bien que tu fais le titre i
après tu fais le malin tu as vu je suis
pas venu là pour parler de quoi que ce
soit ben tu fais mal à l'assumer
jusqu'au bout et puis après quand tu as
porté plainte
tu as vu nous on n'est pas là pour ça tu
vois les mois
mais la bd après il ya aussi le parisien
non non non non non non mais moi j'avais
espoir était alors majeure est attendu
ici pour parler calmement un plateau
télé à venir non mais non ya pas de coup
de pression déclare donc si on a on
arrête bataille mais j'ai dit ok on sait
pas lequel mais man alors qu'elle m'a
dit pourquoi vous êtes contre sans
menacer son adresse mes joues bien mais
fermement m'écouter où l'accusé à
l'époque et pas vous faut arrêter ça
prenne des années que ouais concours
soient choqués paternité mais mes
inspecteurs ou des années mais je suis
je suis qui je vis et je me remets oui
mais mesure jobé maman si on ne respecte
pas je peux parler qui les attendait pas
des leçons sur le réseau des enfants le
débat le débat c'est ça pourquoi vous
êtes choqué qu'on mette en avant les
blessés pas plus grave que ça vous
dérange moi personnellement je suis
choqué voilà pourquoi mais un enfant ça
se protège quand on fait un bon d'accord
vous et vos enfants vous les mettez sur
les réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gens
malsains qui traînent sur les réseaux
sociaux on a des de toutes sortes de
gens malsains je vais pas de donner des
trucs mais il ya des pédophiles il ya
aujourd'hui on met nos enfants sur les
réseaux sociaux
d'accord c'est les enfants voilà les
colts d'accord sortie d'école le premier
enfant qu'on va voir ça va être lekker
ça va être le vôtre d'accord donc c'est
un vrai fondamente des enfants couteau
that dangereux que ces abus lycée mais
c'est très malsain aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les candidats de télé
réalité on peut se dire se font de
l'argent dessus tout le monde le sait
d'accord alors
bizarrement les bdd star de télé réalité
ils ont 500 1000 followers
j'habite à l'étranger donc déjà
l'argument de l'école il fonctionne pas
c'est à dire que souvent ces candidats
habitent dans des pays étrangers vont
aller danser des écoles qui sont assez
sûr protégé moi je suis aussi cynique
que toi je t'ai pas que enfin voilà ce
que tu penses que tu veux mais moi je
suis convaincu qu'il ya quand même un
tout petit peu de naïveté dans la façon
qu'ils ont d'exposer leurs enfants en
disant voilà peut-être qu'il aura très
tôt un compte instagram
il va gagner des sous avec et moi aussi
je suis devenue cliente de ces trucs là
par exemple la fille de le fils de
caractère haguenau qui s'appelle les
eaux mais tous les matins je le regarde
ça m'amuse je suis sam attendri alors je
suis maman voilà il score mais de la
question aller simple clairement est ce
que c'est un business
oui oui j'ai franchement je suis très
choqué et magali je pense que là vous
devrez intervenir vous avez jamais en
main vous êtes la papesse non mais pas
dans le débat pas dans le débat
vous êtes la papesse de tout ça c'est
vous qui organisez et là il ya une
dérive vraiment dangereux et laissez moi
finir
effectivement on exhibe les enfants ce
qui se passe c'est que ces stars de
télé-réalité moi par exemple j'adore
nabila mais ces stars là elles ne
peuvent plus se montrer s'exhiber de la
même manière lorsqu'elles ont un enfant
donc elle trouve la méthode de l'enfant
pour configurer existants et en à
billère pour côte nord c'est la seule
qui ne met pas en avant vieux blancs non
mais vous employer le mot soir elles ne
peuvent le globalement elle au pluriel
est il du soleil par an ils peuvent plus
faire de il se montrait pareillement et
donc ils prennent le prisme de l'enfance
est hyper dangereux oui c'est
rémunérateurs mais c'est dangereux on va
vers de graves dérives et franchement il
faut y mettre un terme
h m alors moi je trouve qu'il faut
savoir vivre avec son temps mais si on
reprend un exemple on parle aujourd'hui
des influenceurs mais certains comédiens
faisait ça aussi avec leurs enfants et à
l'époque ça a choqué ou pas certaines
personnes en exposant leurs buts et
leurs enfants dans la presse pour un
coup d'envoi la wii aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui on vient avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est une autre forme
mais là c'est au verbe haut rhin
clairement à but lucratif
aujourd'hui sur instagram on les utilise
et moi sincèrement je suis pas plus
choqué que ça et on est les premières
regarder à wil et comme elle le dit
gignac a donc on peut être attendris et
et je suis pas voilà jeu a reçu ensuite
évacué par par vos propos qui sont en
effet très noble quand on vous entend
mais moi je comprends que ça le choc
je voulais la loi d'être choqués voilà
ça reste une forme de voyeurisme et moi
je moi je prends mes nièces censure en
vidéo sur instagram avec moi pas moi qui
le met une fois temps en temps je
dénigre pas ça ces enfants tout le monde
a envie de montrer la beauté des enfants
c'est quelque chose de normal d'accord
maintenant de leur créer un compte
instagram tous les jours l'alimenter
avec des photos toujours navire moi j'ai
clark honte pour mes nièces que
j'alimente et les un contre un contre
salon tir et moi on manage to glace et
moi c'est pour aider vos en famille
qu'on en fasse à ce que je parle pas de
ça elles sont elles sont super mais
voilà et je l'aimé et on fait des vidéos
et elles ont alors redemander excuses
une première chose c'est que pour
protéger ces enfants déjà peu vite et
faire une vidéo volant parce que les
enfants des autres on peut les tuer
comme ça donc ensuite deuxièmement je
vois pas en quoi on monétise un enfant
et en quoi on se fait du blé parce que
je reprend les termes sur les enfants
aujourd'hui carla mais je veux tu parles
pas de calais en paca l'ensemble
d'accord moi j'ai aucun enfant là dans
les gens qu'on a montré qui a été
monétisées c'est à dire qu'il n'ya aucun
de ces candidats là d'accord on à
monétiser l'image de son enfance et en
même temps des questions l'alcool et
bien c'est son bétail un peu vous c'est
très pervers comme idée parce que vous
faites un buzz de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas et c'est vous qui avez des
idées pervers parce qu'en réalité ces
gens là n'ont jamais demandé le moindre
centime pour faire faire la promotion à
l'heure zéro alors ces poursuites
ensuite au troisième et ça je le sais et
je pense quand et si moi je suis ensuite
deuxièmement pour information quand ils
ont tourné la vidéo de carla donc du
petit bébé ruby d'accord ils ont touché
un cachet qui a été directement placée
sur le compte de la petite
d'accord c'est à dire que la petite
effectivement tout a été placé sur un
compte épargne la petite c'est un cachet
de production d'accord ce n'est pas de
la publicité ya pas de promotion
déguisement mais là vous jouez sur les
mots on pouvait pas dire là
non non non non mais ils se font de
l'argent mais à réserver tracé serait
pas crédible
donc c'est les parents en même temps
maintenant mais je l'avais l'utilisation
quand un influenceur met en scène des
enfants ça va leur créer la popularité
donc de l'audience et donc de l'audience
à faire de la motivation chaleur compte
c'est de cette manière dont on sait
qu'elles vous explique serge des
candidats télé réalité qui y vivent
nabila on la connaît depuis qu'elle a 17
ou 18 ans d'accord aujourd'hui elle a
grandi ces gens là les ans les gens les
aiment ils ont un public qu'il faut
respecter
on a besoin de voir comment et
grandissent calais la vie quelqu'un
c'est la réalité avoir un enfant
aujourd'hui ça la vraie vie c'est vous
qui est pervers à chaque pas qu'on parle
de ça et qu'est ce qui est mal dans un
enfant qu'on monte sur instagram c'est
beau un bébé toutes les photos convoité
petites ruelles de cette auto-évaluation
donc la dent alors on va conclure pour
vous et pour le coup ce soit clair aucun
de ces candidats là ne se fait de
l'argent en mettant leurs enfants sur
instagram pour mon film ok mais quand
ils se font filmer en train d'accoucher
mais pas que ces comptes et oui ces
faits prouvent à kasserine a en fait la
télé-réalité c'est doivent jamais vous
êtes bien passé parce que la téléralité
la téléralité s'est montrée la vie des
gens les voir voir comment aider vos
lieux tu étais un peu on va on va
reparler merci monsieur d'être passés
nous voir mais je vois que ça ça crée
beaucoup d'excitation ce débat